les séries c'est l'heure de la mise au
point va recevoir quelqu'un qui a été au
cœur des débats hier soir Daniel Riolo
qui a affirmé que des gens que dans les
prisons étaient des sous-citoyens et
dont la déclaration a créé un tollé sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur ce plateau
voilà il y a voilà on a on a précisé
voilà la déclaration de Daniel hier
petit récap et il est avec nous juste
après c'est parti
depuis plusieurs années Daniel Riolo
intervient sur RMC où il n’hésite pas à
donner son avis parfois tranché ce sont
tous des Guignols tous des Guignols mais
hier lors d'un débat sur l'accès
Internet pour les prisonniers dans
l'émission d'Estelle Denis le
chroniqueur s'est emporté son détruire
citoyens qui ont fauté qui ont causé du
tort à la société madame sa compagne
Géraldine maillet a tenu à le défendre
sur notre plateau et on part les mêmes
droits que ceux qui sont
aucune de la société sauf que pour
beaucoup ces propos ne sont pas
acceptables et ont déclenché la colère
des chroniqueurs c'est pas du tout des
sous-citoyens c'est des citoyens qui ont
fait une erreur on est prisonnier mais
on a des droits donc on n'est pas un
citoyen c'est aussi simple que ça voilà
alors lynché dans TPMP après avoir
qualifié les prisonniers de
sous-citoyens Daniel Riolo répond au
chroniqueurs merci Daniel Riolo d'être
avec nous merci d'être là Daniel parce
que hier ça ça a quand même secoué et
Daniel et là aujourd'hui donc déjà
franchement on peut lui dire bravo parce
que c'est vrai qu'il y en a plein qui
sont
[Applaudissements]
jamais avec des notes mais là tu veux
que je te dise est-ce que tu veux
démarrer ou est-ce que tu veux écouter
ce qu'on va dire les chroniqueurs et
peut-être après
une question je vais m'adresser à ceux
qui étaient là ah non violette il était
pas là hier Jean-Michel
et qui ont parlé notamment Gilles
bonjour Daniel
tu me regardes dans les yeux tu me dis
que tu as vu la séquence en entier dans
Estelle midi je l'ai lu non non non non
est-ce que tu as vu est-ce que tu as vu
la séquence
il y a un extrait Twitter il y a pas de
verbatif est-ce que tu as vu la 56 non
tu n'as pas bien fait ton travail Daniel
Moreau
j'ai regardé l'émission oui
en entier j'ai même parlé avec Estelle
en direct est-ce qu'on ait la séquence
au moins aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est en
entier la séquence
la prison depuis des années moi ce que
j'entends c'est que c'est réinsérer
c'est éviter la récidive c'est le
confort dans les prisons la France est
sanctionné machin mais citoyens français
tout ça il en a rien à cirer
qui ont voté qui ont causé du tort à la
société madame
bon c'est pas du tout la séquence en
entier mais c'est pas grave parce que
parce que dans la séquence en entier je
crois que je commence par ça je vais
immédiatement la distinction entre le
prisonnier on va dire lourd le
terroriste l'assassin d'enfant le serial
killer et je crois que j'utilise
l'expression de mémoire celui qui vole
une pomme à l'épicier du coin alors donc
à partir du moment où tu sais que j'ai
la version longue hein on va pas la
passer c'est bon
je fais la distinction entre différents
prisonniers et d'ailleurs hier je crois
que votre débat a terminé là-dessus je
crois même que Raymond voulait buter les
terroristes il était prêt
ils sont très virulentes contre contre
ceux qui étaient des prisonniers avec
des dossiers voilà donc moi j'ai fait
cette distinction donc ensuite il y a le
mot citoyen et là bon
je suis désolé si vous comprenez pas la
définition de citoyen je crois que il y
a que des films qui a compris puisque
elle elle a dit quelque chose de très
juste et moi aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'elle a parlé de droit et de
devoirs parce que citoyens
c'est pas c'est pas dire je sais pas qui
a voulu faire une analogie absolument
ridicule sous homme et tout ça n'a rien
à voir citoyen c'est des droits et des
devoirs pourquoi on dit parfois vous
savez il y a des gens qui sont illust
citoyens d'honneur dans une ville mais
c'est ce qui se sont comportés super
bien qu'ils ont fait briller la ville et
donc ils reçoivent donc ça veut dire
qu'ils sont des surcitoyens ils sont
mieux que le citoyen normal et celui qui
est en prison comme il a pas respecté
les valeurs de civisme qui en gros il
s'est pas comporté comme un bon citoyen
je suis parfaitement habilité à dire que
c'est un sous citoyen mais quand il sort
de prison comme Marco par ailleurs on se
connaît Marco donc hein c'est un citoyen
normal Marco on a payé sa dette à la
société importante c'est on va on oublie
les citoyens les prisonniers qu'est-ce
que tu penses de moi Ré
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait une faute grave je t'ai vu
plusieurs fois au restaurant et puis tu
as un garçon qui m'a qui m'a dit des
choses que j'ai aimé la vérité
franchement je t'ai même adoré oui mais
attends calme-toi
je crois que tu l'as pas invité j'ai
envie de savoir qu'est-ce que tu
mélanges dans tout ça qu'est-ce que tu
penses de l'escroquerie que j'ai fait
c'est tout thème ah non mais là bah si
qu'est-ce que tu penses de moi je suis
un sous-titoyable j'ai fait une connerie
j'ai pas fait de connerie
jusque juste quelque chose que j'ai faim
je sais que j'ai fait à partir du moment
où une personne va en prison j'imagine
c'est parce qu'elle a fauté tu es sorti
de prison tu es un citoyen normal on va
bouffer ensemble après si tu veux dire
tu fais des enfants si tu avais
terroriste je pense que tu crois qu'il y
a pas en prison c'est ce qu'on disait
hier voilà c'est exactement
pour de vrai excuse-moi qu'est-ce qu'il
faut un mec qui a pas de permis qui va
en prison oui mais attends mais dis-moi
c'est un souci citoyen non on va passer
autre chose mais si c'est prouver
évidemment on est plus dans le proposer
est-ce que quand Marco était au placard
est-ce que c'est un souci citoyen bah
oui parce qu'il a pas les mêmes droits
il a même pas la liberté d'aller venir
il est pas comme un citoyen normal il
est pas il est pas comme toi c'est
normal oui ça veut dire que tu n'as pas
les mêmes droits tu peux pas exercer tes
droits alors il y a ceux qui sont les
terroristes carrément ils ont plus leurs
droits s'ils peuvent plus voter ils sont
plus dans l'autre sens social et
politique j'ai plus le droit de voter
c'est pareil ah ben si je savais pas
ouais mais j'ai pas l'air de voter j'ai
vraiment du plaisir
je suis en porte-à-faux parce que
j'adore Daniel je l'écoute à la radio
tous les soirs j'envoie des textos je
vais dire parce que moi je me dégonfle
jamais c'est pas parce que tu es là et
des Géraldine des fois je l'envoie des
textos je dis énorme Daniel ce qu'il a
dit soir énormément donc là par contre
je veux juste que tu te mettes à la la
base de ceux qui t'écoutent à la radio
qui sont en prison et qui est en prison
mais il y a tout le monde n'a pas le
même mécanisme que toi mental tout le
monde n'a pas les mêmes bagages mental
des fois il y a des gens des fois il y a
des gens ils se sentent blessés sous
citoyens tu veux dire quoi on est des
sous-mer pourquoi tu nous parles comme
ça
tu acceptes qu'il y a des gens qui
peuvent l'entendre comme ça accepte
qu'il y a des gens comme il a dit moi
pour des permis d'école je sais pas les
pensées qu'on va pas comprendre la
définition de citoyen parce que toi tu
es cultivé tu as ta sémantique de mots
tu as peut-être à thé vert tu as tes
adjectifs il y a des gens qui veulent
pas il y a des gens tout citoyens
c'est ça qui a posé ça
visiblement bon comme d'habitude sur
Twitter les deux les gens comprennent
rien mais pas tout hier soir j'entends
dans l'émission vous faites une sorte de
mini procès Cyril enfin ces équipes me
dit tu veux venir pour t'expliquer mais
je viens donc à partir du moment où on
s'explique vous avez compris ce que
c'était qu'un citoyen le film avait
compris maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu dis que sous citoyen c'est une
insulte pour les gens qui sont en prison
mais vraiment je t'adore et tout le
monde enfin Dieu sait que je t'adore
mais quand tu es en prison c'est que tu
as insulté la citoyenneté
facile ce qui est facile avec Delphine
avec même avec moi avec Daniel avec
Géraldine avec Bernard tout ce qui est
facile c'est qu'on a pas foutu moi j'ai
fait deux jours garde à vue c'est que
dalle c'est rien du tout on n'a pas
foutu un pied en prison et on parle de
ce qui se passe en prison ne parlons pas
de ce qu'on connaît pas et ne jugeons
pas il y a des gens bien en prison même
s'ils ont voté
il y en a qui ont merdé avec des permis
de conduire il y en a qui ont merdé
parce qu'ils avaient besoin du cannabis
ils regrette mais même le mec qui a
conduit avec un un faux permis citoyen
si appartenant il a pas respecté les
trois valeurs principales de la
citoyenneté le civisme la civilité et la
solidarité dans le laps de temps où il
est confronté à la prison c'est un souci
après c'est fini on est en 2022 il y a
100 ans tu aurais pu dire ça aujourd'hui
tout le monde pense à sa gueule il y a
des gens qui vont en prison je
t'explique calme-toi et il t'a dit tout
à l'heure tu étais un grand monsieur
il y a une chose que je vais te dire et
ça c'est réel je te le promets que c'est
vrai je te donne ma parole que c'est
vrai tout ce que tu dis tu as aussi
raison mais tu as tort énormément
pourquoi c'est parce que l'État mais
enfin la justice mélange le bon et le
mauvais donc on devient tous des mères
dont je viens on se mélange mais la
seule différence ça c'est un autre
problème ici c'est le même problème
parce que celui-là qui est en prison
c'est un sous citoyen le problème qui se
passe c'est quand tu as en face de toi
toi tu as volé une pomme tu as volé une
pomme tu veux travailler tu veux sortir
tu veux plus aller en prison [ __ ] un
mec qui a tué trois mecs il est en face
de toi mais quel poids que tu as mais
quel poids arrivé un milliard de fois le
mec qui vient il vient me voir moi je
suis un financier ok qui n'a pas volé
moi la seule différence j'ai volé mais
la seule différence j'ai remis
l'économie en face ça veut dire j'ai
Robert c'est mon argent mais par contre
on se comprend pas le vol le voleur de
pommes et et
ce n'est pas la soucis il a fait une
entorse
permis de conduire madame certainement
pas la première fois chaque fois obligé
de travailler qui est obligé de
travailler il a une famille et il a pu
de permis il est chauffeurs livreurs
parle d'autre chose
moi tout à l'heure je t'ai entendu dans
un débat personne t'a contredit tu dis
tu as eu l'air de dire tu as eu l'air de
dire que la cavale quand on est pauvre
ou issu d'un milieu défavorisé on peut
comprendre
qu'on puisse tomber dans le dans le vol
ou dans la délinquante et bien moi je
suis pas d'accord avec ça c'est une
insulte contre tous les gens qui
viennent de milieu défavorisés et moi je
viens pas d'un milieu aisé justement mes
parents sont venus en France il
n'avaient rien qui est blonde ils ont
tout construit non mais attends attends
attends attends
tous les
tous les gens qui sont issus de
défavoriser ne tombent pas dans la
délinquance il faut surtout pas envoyer
ce message là et dans ton livre tu
envoies un message c'est dommage que tu
parles pas de ça parce qu'il y a un
passage dans ton livre qui est
extrêmement touchant où tu dis qu'il y a
une forme de regret évidemment dans tout
ce que tu as fait tu demandes c'est même
assez il y a des passages qui sont
touchants dans ton bouquin et alors
après que tu dis sa famille aussi voilà
qui regrette sa famille il parle de il
parle de choses qui sont fortes et assez
belles alors après c'est vrai que sur
les plateaux télé bon on te fait parler
du côté on aime bien on aime bien
écouter tes histoires et quand on a le
les fois on s'est retrouvé au resto
c'est vrai que j'aime bien t'écouter
raconter des histoires mais j'aimerais
bien que tu envoies également le message
que aller en tôle c'est c'est pas bien
du tout
il faut être capable d'aller en prison
je sais même pas qui parlent en prison
quand on regarde à vue et tu sais que tu
vas en prison tu chies dans ton froc
mais tu chies réellement dans ton coin
j'imagine une fois que tu as en prison
que tu as envie de te libérer de la
prison mais est-ce que quand on dit on
va il faut pas récidiver mais à l'autre
quand tu vas en prison tu as un toutou
t'es naze tu as peur tu es pas bien mais
tu ressors un lion tu ressors un méchant
pourquoi c'est parce qu'à l'intérieur
tout est méchant il y a des méchants
mais il y a des bons il y a des mecs qui
votent sur robe bien sûr il y en a
beaucoup
parce qu'on l'a pas dit mais le débat
hier c'était pas du tout ça le débat
c'était faut-il donner Internet aux
prisonniers là-dessus et moi j'ai dit
moi j'ai dit pour une grosse partie des
prisonniers j'ai aucun souci en revanche
que Nordahl Lelandais il est un compte
Facebook ou qu'un terroriste
et personne ne l'a regardé
d'ailleurs je voulais t'en parler je
voulais faire un petit peu Delphine
j'ai pas bossé mais j'ai compris quand
même ce que tu as dit
ça va le melon là
j'ai fait 12 ans dans ma vie aujourd'hui
j'ai vraiment des séquelles est-ce que
je suis heureux tu crois est-ce que je
suis heureux ça c'est une bonne question
je pense que tu dois l'être un peu plus
aujourd'hui
je suis l'homme le plus malheureux du
monde tu veux savoir pourquoi c'est que
ma vie a une étiquette désagréable parce
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
j'en pleure tous les jours de pas avoir
une vie normale de rater 12 ans de ta
vie de ne pas avoir ta famille de ne pas
avoir tes enfants de tu sais même pas
comment ils ont grandi tu les achètes
seulement tu donnes de l'argent pour
qu'il grandisse je suis pas beau je suis
pas beau à voir et mais il y a une chose
que je vais te dire c'est pas le même
sujet moi je regrette moi je dis à tout
le monde n'y allez pas en prison mais
j'adore ce message pour de vrai il y a
une chose que je vais te dire et
parle-moi franchement et parle-moi et
dis-moi la vérité ne mens pas ne mens
pas
ne dis pas et je vais aller dans ton
sens dans un truc qui est vrai que tu as
dit quelque chose de vrai ta faim tu as
pas mangé depuis 10 jours ne me mens pas
ne me ment pas tu passes devant un
étalage il y a des fruits tu vas pas
chez l'envoler 10 jours il y a des
chances il y a des chances je vais te la
faire autrement ta femme et tes enfants
tu vas pas les voler un kilo de pommes
ne ment pas
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux que si tu veux que je te
répondeur dans mon process de vie dans
mon éducation on m'a d'abord dit fait
tout pour aller travailler même si c'est
difficile tu as du travail lève-toi le
cul tôt le matin s'il faut j'ai eu la
chance de pas trop le faire parce que je
fais pas un métier
et je suis très heureux dans ma vie
pas de gueule il y en a quand ils vont
chercher du travail ils ont tellement
moche
va bosser à l'école respecter professeur
c'est ça les messages qu'il faut envoyer
à la société aujourd'hui va à l'école
essaie de bosser
ensuite tu trouveras un travail en
France oui moi je suis physique
d'immigrés moi je suis ici Marco non
mais je t'ai est-ce que tu es né en
France oui d'accord est-ce que tu sais
pourquoi on allait à l'école nous pour
les allocations familiales pour manger
moi c'est pas le message qu'on m'a
envoyé
s'il vous plaît gilbertez tu voulais
dire un truc sur elle a dit franchement
alors Daniel non mais
alors justement Daniel fait une analyse
sémantique de sous-citoyens sous citoyen
c'est humiliant c'est dégradant tous les
prisonniers moi j'ai quelqu'un moi j'ai
quelqu'un j'ai quelqu'un dans ma famille
très proche qui a fait de la prison
récemment voilà j'ai parlé j'ai parlé de
ce que vous avez dit j'ai parlé de ce
terme sous citoyen il m'a dit mais c'est
pas possible c'est une humiliation c'est
terrible sous citoyen je suis désolé
avec l'intelligence que vous avez je
l'ai dit hier je le redis vous êtes
intelligent vous savez très bien que
c'est assimilé à sous homme et bien non
mais si c'est ce que vous avez voulu
combat
tu es un ancien journaliste tu l'es
peut-être encore maintenant tu viens sur
un plateau de Télé 2 millions de
personnes te regardent tous les soirs
ton rôle c'est d'expliquer les choses
pour expliquer les choses déjà de
regarder les séquences en entier et
ensuite d'expliquer les choses Gilles de
ne pas mentir de dire les choses comme
ils sont aussi citoyens c'est un sens ça
a une définition
et je suis ici pour expliquer qu'ils se
sont trompés voilà il y a un truc Marco
je veux juste comprendre quelque chose
il a été en prison trop beau frère
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas dit que c'était mon beau-frère
je sais que c'est ton beau-frère mais
pourquoi
tu regardes Cyril je te pose une
question
je veux savoir est-ce qu'il a volé une
pomme non mais arrête avec cette pomme
arrête avec cette pomme Marco alors
justement
Gilles hier tu as dit que les
prisonniers n'étaient pas des
sous-citoyens
on prend tout à fait moi je suis assez
d'accord avec toi là dessus après voilà
et Daniel a expliqué qu'en fait pour lui
ce qui n'avait pas les mêmes droits que
les autres citoyens voilà c'est ça en
fait parce que il met mais bon pour moi
les les prisonniers sont ne sont pas des
sous-citoyens et voilà j'ai énormément
d'amis je vous le dis qui sont qui sont
placards qui nous regardent tous les
soirs et d'ailleurs on est un peu leur
bouffées d'oxygène
et je les adore et puis et on espère
qu'il y en a plein qui veulent se
réinsérer sur le repas bien sûr tout ça
et pour la plupart pour la plupart c'est
ça et j'ai énormément de potes qui sont
sortis tu sais Marco et qui maintenant
font un travail magnifique
dans le travail dans la réalité
exactement tu vas les pommes ou pas
maintenant tu vas avoir répondu si je
t'ai dit au bout de 10 jours il est
possible que la pomme je la vole pour
aller plus loin je pense que c'est pas
dans mon éducation
à ça je te demande est-ce que tu l'as
veules
je t'ai répondu comme tous les jours si
j'ai la dalle la pomme je vais la voler
je te dis
non en fait en fait la vérité c'est que
je vais demander je vais je vais je vais
demander au vendeur de me dire dégage
3 millions comme toi
deux questions déjà qu'est-ce que tu
penses de la vie de Gilles voilà et
qu'est-ce que tu penses de dedans mais
qu'est-ce que tu penses également du du
coup de foudre de Daniel
avait très bon goût donc de ce côté-là
son humour sa bonne foi sa mauvaise foi
ça tendresse et je trouve que c'était un
très beau livre avec beaucoup d'humour
et j'ai préféré largement le livre à la
série et Dieu sait que la série j'avais
aimé Gilles et ensuite concernant Gilles
alors Gilles je comprends son son
emportement sur l'expression
sous-citoyen mais c'est le même Gilles
Verdez qui nous dit hier qu'il faut pas
faire une partie de saute non mais même
avec des sous députés du coup oui oui
donc c'est des sous-définis exactement
qui représente combien de millions de
Français et oui il méprise ça j'ai une
petite question pour vous Daniel est-ce
que tu voles les pommes
quand le footballeur Patrice Evra a
sorti son autobiographie il est venu ici
sur le plateau de Touche pas à mon poste
il est pas venu dans l'After Foot sauf
alors de ma part il est pas venu chez
vous non parce qu'on fait il est allé
dans l'émission de Jérôme roten c'est
dans cette émission qu'on reçoit les
gros invités et j'ai une phrase de vous
mais je pense qu'elle est fausse donc je
vais vous la citer vous allez démentir
je pense qu'il y a des fausses
est-ce que vous avez dit Evra préfère
aller dans une émission de
divertissement se faire cirer le cul par
un animateur qui a la même mentalité
racaille que lui plutôt que de se rendre
dans une émission intelligente comme la
nôtre qui raconte la vérité c'est pas de
vous ça quel balance
[Applaudissements]
regarde arrête-toi regarde Marco il faut
dire des conneries mais pas toi tu as un
journaliste un passage de ton livre tu
l'as écrit donc je demande à Daniel il
l'a dit moi non mais c'est pas grave
non mais donc c'est faux je sais même
pas de quoi tu parles là
c'est facile
en plus
tu penses que je suis assez con pour
dire du mal de l'émission ou bien
honnêtement
franchement
[Rires]
en tout cas c'est toujours pareil c'est
plus quoi dire des conneries